researchers at Yale University did a
cognitive study on 300 dogs and they
found out that almost in all
circumstances dogs pretty much act like
humans so it's a huge huge study which I
don't want to get into all of it but
there is a link right down below if you
want to see the exact study and what
they did there's also a local news story
that'll kind of sum it up for you
I have no what what happened you stole
my pen didn't stole your pen just like a
dog went steal a bone yeah I like that
you acted it out a little bit so yeah so
it's really interesting it doesn't
surprise me we're all dog owners it
doesn't surprise me that dogs behave the
way people behave does it does it shock
you brownie acts just like Jimmy Dore
doesn't he well the problem is like I
resisted getting a Kindle for so long
and I got one and now my dog has it all
the time he's he loved he's he's reading
a dog's life and mostly a lot of porn
but dogs don't have great attention
spans either which I think you're
proving is III think that dogs have a
human emotes what that studies saying
that that dogs dogs basically react to
things so they did a bunch of things
where they would hide things and they
found out that dogs would go about
finding things the same way humans would
use the same senses I didn't like it
when the they're human which I hate
first of all it's this is a Yale study
so all those dogs are smarter than oh
yeah they'd like if I read it correctly
was that the you you'd be reading a book
and then that you'd put the book down
your dog would see if with the book down
and then someone another person would
come in and take the book and the dogs
didn't like that that your book was
taken so really yes so the dog would get
defensive and then would be barking at
people and things like that I mean we
look a lot of this I think is inherent
it's just like I've said evolution with
dogs right let's uh let's clear
something up though I have I have three
dogs yes sort of now feel like I'll
always have three dogs and uh and this
is just true it's painful for people to
hear take the dumbest person you've ever
met in your entire life yeah
and they are smarter than the smartest
dog this is not true it's a hundred
percent and it's not it is a hundred but
we all know the same person
one person just by lots of basil who are
dumber than dogs nope and and you know a
dump you're talking like a mentally
handicapped person the dog is dumber
than a mentally hang on the main spec
yeah I'm not singling any type of person
out I wasn't trying that could you say a
dumb person regular working don't Percy
like a dolphin or a whale or a dog they
that maybe they don't they can't they
don't have the gift of language they
don't have that part of the brain but
they have other parts of their brain
that are more developed than ours than
ever actually smarter in certain ways
than us so we what way well I think like
they can distinguish smells better than
we do they can distinguish facial
perceptions better than we do so they so
they're smarter in a lot of ways that
way plus you know you ever see a
well-trained dog they're much smarter
than a lot of people I know so I'm not
done don't you ever come home from a
rough day at work or something bad
happen your purse life or something and
your dog can sense it now I know that
doesn't necessarily mean smarts because
that could just be their responding no
no it could be dogs can smell kids they
can tell when you have cancer they're
smarter than doctors just like [ __ ] dogs
that can do that no they can do that
thank you could ones I'll buy me one one
once ever
my dog does that so he thought if I piss
them off ago what's that I go what
nothing I thought I smelled cancer do
you guys think you love your dogs in a
deeper way than maybe some people that
you know maybe even some family members
like I love my dog so much I took her I
was telling you guys before we started
she had her teeth cleaned yesterday so
they had to you know put her under and
really from like 9:00 a.m. oh my gosh I
have to be put under to brush their
teeth they're geniuses and I said she
wouldn't bite but they didn't trust me
they want to do it anyway but really
from like 9:00 a.m. to like 5:00 p.m.
the whole day I was like ah what it you
know it's one in a hundred thousand that
don't wake up from the anesthesia and I
was freaking out all day long and even
now it's a day later and she's still a
little loopy but as thing and how much I
love this animal has given me so much
comfort and joy more than I love some
people that are pretty close to me I
think they put me under to get a
colonoscopy okay
so you don't have to be smart to get a
stick stop
I think could brush your teeth a little
more complicated and sticking this wand
up your asses yes I know my dog and it's
amazing that do dogs also have emotions
you know I had a sister who tried to
tell me that they don't have a motion
assault instinct so you don't have to
that's not true dogs certainly have
emotions right and they're they're
they're emotional beings my dog could
sense when I was depressed and needed
his my old dog and he would come over
and comfort me when I was standing in a
corner crying not knowing what to do
with my life and he knew and so there's
a certain intelligence is I and I bet
the thing is two dogs never do anything
to really piss me off like they never
they never reveal a secret you told them
they never tried to [ __ ] your girlfriend
they never steal money from you two
never tried to they never make fun of
you or denigrate your good work so then
I always start illegal Wars how do you
not say that that's yours but I always
said that's what makes you love them
more there's always just positive things
coming from your dog that's I love my
dog certainly more than a lot of
bringing us home do you love your dog
more than you love some people that are
everybody told me including dog owners
including one of my best friends was a
dog owner and he said you know when you
have a child as I now like my kid is
almost - you'll it will change how you
feel about your dog's you'll still love
them but he was wrong it hasn't in
anyway it hasn't you know you're the
second person I've heard say that so I
don't I mean don't get me wrong if their
fyke I had there's a fire and I can only
choose one in a fake scenario like like
the terrorism ticking time bomb thing do
you torture somebody you know I'd save
my daughter but I love I don't Bob is uh
I like I love Bob almost as much as if
there's a ticking time bomb and there's
a dog and Sam Harris I'm taking the dog
cyber - all of this is a couple weeks
ago I had a dream that I lost my dog and
that Ben mankiewicz found my dog and
brought her back to me and I told Ben
that and he literally got white in the
face this is totally true and you said
to me that just the day before you found
a stray dog on the street and brought it
back to their owners so there is
something different with dogs what do
you think let us know the comment
section
you